[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 me acompaña en el estudio
Rosa Pérez mateu Rosa bienvenida buena
mañana de jueves y vamos con un
reportaje especial abrimos con la
investigación del Washington post
titulada generales y almirantes
estadounidenses retirados consiguen
trabajos de alto Rango con el príncipe
heredero de Arabia Saudita turbia
situación no entre Estados Unidos pues
funcionarios que pertenecieron al cuerpo
militar de Estados Unidos con Arabia
Saudita efectivamente Y como bien
comentas el titular está muy centrado en
Arabia Saudita sin embargo esta práctica
se extiende a otros países y la
investigación se podría sintetizar En
las siguientes líneas más de 500
militares estadounidenses retirados
incluidos decenas de generales y
almirantes han aceptado trabajos
lucrativos desde 2015 trabajando para
gobiernos extranjeros principalmente en
países conocidos por abusos contra los
recursos humanos y represión política
Rosa entonces entremos en detalles los
funcionarios de Estados Unidos conocen
esta práctica efectivamente y de hecho
los soldados retirados del ejército
necesitan la aprobación de la que era su
rama en las fuerzas armadas así como del
departamento de estado para poder
trabajar para las autoridades de otros
países sin embargo denuncia el la
Washington post que a la práctica Esta
aprobación es automática que casi no se
estudian los antecedentes ni los
expedientes de hecho dice el periódico
que ha encontrado decenas de ex
militares en linkedin que han trabajado
para países sobre todo del Golfo sin que
consen en los registros unos registros
que por otro lado en la periódico
Washington post denuncia que durante
mucho tiempo en el gobierno
estadounidense ha intentado mantener en
la sombra como ese periódico para
acceder a esta información Rosa no como
que lo que siempre preguntamos cuando
salen estos reportajes especiales
efectivamente como debían denuncia no la
administración intentaba mantener estos
registros ocultos el Washington post
denunció tanto al departamento de estado
como a las fuerzas armadas ante la
justicia Federal amparándose en la
llamada ley de la libertad de
información y tras una batalla de dos
años obtuvo acceso a 4000 páginas de
información con los registros de 450 ex
soldados y como curiosidad Los abogados
que defendían a los digamos al
departamento tanto
al departamento de estado como las
fuerzas armadas decían argumentaban que
divulgar la información podría someter a
los ex militares avergüenza y acoso y
dañar injustamente su reputación pública
no unos argumentos que ya revelan cierta
conciencia de que esta actividad es
ciertamente cuestionable sin embargo la
juez falló Que la ciudadanía la
población tiene derecho a conocer este
tipo de información y así la divulgado
el Washington post Rosa vamos con
algunos puntos más destacados de esta
investigación Sí dice que la
contratación no de ex personal militar
estadounidense por parte de las
monarquías del Golfo se ha acelerado en
la última década a medida que se han
estrechado las relaciones con el
pentágono por ejemplo como decíamos no
se centra en Arabia Saudita a pesar de
que también comenta el caso de emiratos
árabes Unidos y de otros países también
como Australia por ejemplo sin embargo
el hecho de centrarse en la relación con
riad responde precisamente a la
problemática no al problemático vínculo
Al menos discursivo que hay entre
Estados Unidos y Arabia Saudita no y por
ejemplo dice mientras exoficiales de
Estados Unidos trabajan directamente o a
través de consultorías para el
Ministerio de defensa de Arabia Saudita
pues Arabia Saudita estado implicado en
la guerra del yemen o también en el
asesinato del periodista jamalka shogi
en 2018 y sin embargo para terminar con
algunos nombres no de altos rangos del
ejército estadounidense que han
trabajado para Saudita pues se incluye
por ejemplo a James quien fue asesor de
seguridad Nacional del presidente Barack
Obama o el general retirado del ejército
que hizo Alexander Quien dirigió la
agencia de seguridad nacional bajo Obama
y bajo el presidente George W Bush